I don't what is what is very important
is that we need to take this seriously
Molly with my food Molly thank you so
much damn it [ __ ] are you sucking
curse at me why can't you eat before
well what's gonna happen Bob is if he's
eating now my food is gonna be here soon
so goddamn it
oh hey my food guy here all right Bob
you just let us know how you're doing I
hate you guys so much
I'm coming in for commander I don't know
there should be talking I can't hear
anything no no I see someone aiming I'm
coming up over here yes I'm ready um
yeah I think if you're are you both
visible this is our commander follow
follow Red Hat man all right I ran into
a pole I'll reload when I get over there
it takes like a minute and a half people
here oh boy I think they're my friend
right in the back of his brain what did
you put your bayonet on how'd you put
your bayonet on
b2a fix bayonets all right I took my one
shot now I need to fall back and reload
for an hour and a half hang on I'm not
hearing any like game sounds are you
guys here in game sounds yeah there's
banging going on I'm not hearing nothing
I got I got a whole lot oh [ __ ] that guy
just died in front of me I don't see
anybody to shoot at yeah where is
everybody I'm just gonna shoot just so I
feel like a part of things we don't
I didn't mean to reload right here let's
get back into cover a little bit we're
about to be overrun reinforce the
contestant area sandwich before we died
all right don't worry guys I've almost
reloaded this gun after all this time oh
I shot at somebody I did I shot at them
they weren't person I shot one shot and
that was it man it really just takes
last stand what we need to we need to
push we need to push okay
all right I'm fixing bayonet I'm gonna
go I think I heard the call for a charge
oh there's people over here just go for
it boys here we go I'm going to charge
mode yeah I caught one oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh I got hit I've been hit
get some charging Oh God right now oh I
got I I was going after the guy with the
flag man those eating sounds are just
disgusting close to the mic please God
do it daddy hell guys we lost oh yeah
it's not good sir yes sir
boys about bayonets fixed up your
bayonets [ __ ] all right I will
fix it it's a good day today
Oh make sure you hit X and get your gun
on your shoulder and do the Marky Marky
oh right right okay that's smart you
look really in formation and I'm [ __ ]
I'm tight in formation they're coming
they're coming
oh I got did I get hit everything's Cao
Lu Zhi oh yeah I'm fum fuzzy is that bad
that's probably not good probably like a
chest shot actually I think I'm getting
better yeah dude I'm feeling better yeah
I already sent the letter to your wife
um well so long as you just send another
one afterwards you know that I only had
the one the one envelope well I mean
okay all right well then I'll just go
visit her then you didn't say anything
like hey move on like the next guy
usually marry and go to bed with those
exact things why would you say that in a
letter to someone's dead husband wife
someone's wife it was okay to move on
because you were no longer in the
picture
well who are you to say that trying to
be thoughtful it's the one you left in
charge of your yeah you did leave me in
charge if they're not inviting me to the
wedding
I am the only deaf soldier on this field
and I will not have this disrespect to
my I'm dead
oh there's thorns and stuff reloading
again everyone I'm reloading my stomach
I don't know I select where I spawn I
don't seem to be able to select where I
spawn I don't know man I don't know Wars
hell
I'm death I care nothing
I'll weave another commander up here is
this our new commander are you my new
daddy
oh my god what why are people dying I
wish I could hear oh wait there I didn't
have my volume turned up on my go
explore now I've got audio oh my god
we've got infiltration dude the flag
bears coming in yes fly bearer oh I got
their flag bearer I'm gonna [ __ ] stab
this guy wait I'm gonna get you okay I
missed him ah oh god ow what got me I
got annihilated
I like the commander look don't get shot
at God these uhh man it's real hard to
tell who's who oh yeah okay I'm going
towards the indicator markers that I've
got here I've just go there I got them I
got a murdered one good job good murder
oh the closer I get to my regiment the
more I've got like a compass now I've
got like oh yeah I've got like info what
the [ __ ] what does the compass mean it
shows the direction I'm just going to
the flagbearer
I'm going here
guys we're cheering in straight it's
amazing charging who's charging they're
charging
oh god that's so many of them oh that's
terrifying
mark wave the [ __ ] flags I
don't have the flag it's just in front
of me wave it's in front of me I can't
wave it
I'm so tired I got a Crouch I'm just
gonna crouch for a bit
I need to carbo-load why are we why are
we following Italy in the Civil War I
don't come for that because where's the
New York regimented for a lot of wait
that's not us yeah no good
all right I'm gonna try to be a flag
bearer if I die you pick it up okay
I've got the flag do you guys see me
wait is he done this wait are you he's
in front of us you guys not see my big
flag I see you okay I don't know if I'm
supposed to wave this flag or something
none of my buttons do anything so holy
[ __ ] indeed holy [ __ ] oh my god there
what I've got a huge flag you wouldn't
know one behind you okay mark yeah we're
right behind you turn on you [ __ ]
okay hallo hi hi it's me no to your
right
oh I'm not saluting you maybe what I'm
to your right mark mark I'm looting you
up no one's saluting me [ __ ] I'm walking
slow I see okay that's you okay good
that's me wait okay
I'm the one aiming at you now no one's
aiming at me mark I swear to God
no one is one who are there multiple
flag guys yeah there's two regiments
I'm with mark here with the other flag
guy why the [ __ ] I've died I feel scared
just having this flag like I don't know
what I'm supposed to do an officer
officer down okay yeah just be careful
people run by that alley the little nook
there so that's a threat oh god oh god
help me you were just there now your dad
wave that [ __ ] wave that [ __ ] how do I
wait I don't there's no waving there
where do I wave it salute mark can you
uh can you you please wave the flag wave
them around does anybody know how to
wave a flag I spawn somewhere else Oh
save me mark oh good yeah wait did you
get here you [ __ ] saved my life man
oh cool oh that was a bad guy just shot
a man
what's up what's up commander say I
can't hear him very well I can't hear
either I think he's saying superb layout
what's that mean so good play out okay
all right
operation cyka blyat it was it was a
Revolutionary War campaign I'm making
Louisville sub what that wasn't real all
right oh my blood is all over you
god damn it's actually disturbing seeing
you just get ripped away right in front
of me like that
I know well I just peeked out I was I
didn't even see anything and it was just
like what are they charging Oh God mind
you bub
oh no he's dr. he what he be boy you're
good keep reloading Adam tell me what
what do I do
thank you I am Alive yes flag stuff I
need you but I'm doing my flag thing so
hard right now in the same hole the
whole time yes I have I I am NOT going
out on that screen for anything
mark what the guy just walked past the
gap I know that happens it's very scary
boys in the alley
yeah mark I'm so scared
I'm you're scared I have no gun
I'm your morale wait wait the flag I
can't wait it's not a waivable thing
just come on yes when are they coming
out with a battle royale mode for this
game that's a good question
Civil War battle royale we're gonna
suppress babe look out I think we're
getting charged from behind I'm dad got
stabbed to death oh there's my compass
okay Oh how'd you I don't know it popped
up flag dropped oh I'm happy Blackberry
anymore that sucks
I wanna be fly berry black bear oh my
god there's some legs on the ground here
I'm not reloaded but I'm charging up
charge honors is a Death Zone okay here
we go charging I think we're about to be
seen from our charges charging stab my
own guy charge charge charge charge
charge
yeah do you want to take the hill yeah
let's go for it double time boys let's
do this I don't know what's Hillier I'm
honest not sure oh god oh god oh god
it's incoming boys Oh incoming Oh God
why aren't I loaded Oh
my guns loaded on the back like a coward
I ran away like a coward all right
oh wait I'm back up okay
oh god oh god oh god wait they're coming
they're coming here we go
and can i spectate do i have to save
this last stand screen forever oh yeah
yeah I think we're winning
38 less people than them good job side
we want to try the rebels boys oh yeah
you want to give it a go I'm gonna be
flyboy all right you be fine it's not
fun it I mean it's scary it's not like
boring you'll you you won't be bored but
these do us a favor and wave the flag
this is us attacking their camp yeah go
tell ya those darn Yankees they won't
know what him let's get out I'm still
reloading commander I trust you
completely
desert my men turn back yeah the
commander led me into [ __ ] guys they
had some discipline shot there did you
hear that wild fire yeah they did those
nuts you can't go home we gotta win this
sucks to hear our friends dying around
it's only a little bit traumatizing take
aim at a game right now
[Applause]
I'm gonna get sure take aim
I'm charging the camp's pocket cut him
out from behind you go get him Bob even
though you were in our regiment out of
wine I was with my bros I was cuz you're
in the wrong regiment that's where I
spawned I spawned with them and I was
like okay these are my friends I know
what I'm missing here taking aim fire
and reload I'm doing my part for the
Confederacy the Confederacy is in it are
we charging we're charging oh [ __ ]
double-click don't charge what's that
mean you hit see until it says double
quick on the bottom right all right
double quick we're not charging for nice
charges all right I don't think they
know our strategy then so let's hit the
ground in front of my feet are probably
fine I think when I lost my flag bearer
status it likes I switch to the other
division oh god oh god here we go here
we go don't Ruby bill should be point oh
my god
all right hold the 10 your life those
goddamn Yankees got the commander DP
Oh God what shot me they can do with
these spawn on either side of us oh my
god
double-click up the gut quick let's do
it up the gut oh hell yeah oh let's go
it boys oh yeah baby
oh no oh bad bad things are happening in
front of me that's so it's such a
different experience from what I'm used
to in Gabe's it's so fun though I'm
maybe gonna spawn in a war-cry know
about our tomato stolen flank which way
we play yes sir yes sir yes sir
[ __ ] we're going for it oh god
we shouldn't go for it looks good to me
sir let's do this
[Applause]
ready sir take that ready sir
someone get the flag ready I'm ready
recharging oh [ __ ] I just died
come on I'm shot immediately I died five
seconds before we charge
yeah that would bet that wait on the
charge was way too long yeah we were on
this being mowed down there's no wait a
second hold your own now all right 10 to
power 15 min are down charge sure I'm
gonna come in and just hammer him to
death I'm gonna come in and I'm a
screaming panic we're retreating
apparently I can hold the line by myself
just let me we're retreating what are
you talking about fleeing hold them
we're falling back I'm ready to go balls
deep sir I'm so ready
oh man that's about to give
[Music]
information somehow uh yeah I was I got
way closer than I thought I would
I hope they heard me wow that's fun oh
[ __ ] that's what happened like that it
is true like for the charges you gotta
commit cuz they can't shoot all of you
they they only got so many points but
they absolutely cannot shoot all of us
yeah they will only shoot most of us
ahead of us they're looking boys final
push
we're rallying let's just kill my
teammate am I an [ __ ]
Oh for god sakes I think I just killed
my teammate again oh god did I just kill
my teammate I think I just killed my
teammate who I think no only a furious
charge can now turn the day into victory
oh okay we should furiously [ __ ] go
that's what it's a serious fury I'm
furious
Oh are we charging ya going yeah I was
sure [ __ ] yeah I got the call for it
so I did it jarred boys okay well there
were like 80 of them there are a lot of
them and they do seem to have the
benefit of all being congregated in one
position why are you in a wagon I'm
stuck in a wagon whoo get out of the
wagon sounds like a new problem I can't
seem to get out of this wagon get out of
the wagon um dude get out of the wagon I
can't go all the way dude there's Batman
around here oh they're killing me in the
wagon in the wagon I got 50 seconds to
run like a mile and a half and kill 30
people 18 seconds boys don't be waiting
yeah we'll win him yeah we're winning
we're definitely winning I think we're
about to lose friends no win we win we
died so much we got our asses handed to
us we're not good yeah no not good
[Music]